see a way out of this because Russia has
been supporting the Assad government
Iran has been supporting the Assad
government yet it seems to be like a
pendulum swinging one way and then the
other what is your solution to a
terrible civil war with millions of
refugees and when can it be done well
this is a better I think but at the same
time I'd like to highlight one thing our
position is based on the concern that
Syria might submerge into the same
situation as Lebanon Syria could serve
as Libya as Libya as Lebanon that was a
slip of the tongue yes Libya the Syria
can become Libya or like Iraq because
you know before the authorities in Iraq
Saddam Hussein himself were destroyed
there were no terrorists there had been
no terrorists let's not forget that
because it's actually people prefer not
to speak about that but who created the
conditions and how the conditions were
created for terrorism to outburst on
that territories isn't that clear how
after the invasion to Iraq the
authorities have been destroyed Saddam
was hand and then the ISIS came there
the Islamic state and what happened in
Libya full disintegration no state at
all even the diplomatic service of the
US have felt losses and and we know this
- about this tragic case in Libya and we
do not want similar scenario to be
implemented in Syria that is the
baseline of our position to support
President Assad and his government at
the moment and we believe that we
believe that it the position is correct
because
it would be difficult to expect anything
else from us under the circumstances
moreover as I think many people even
agree with that position and I have
mentioned for several times
Iraq I've mentioned Iraq several times
we know the situation they will know
what is happening the u.s. are
supporting Iraq now they are arming the
army they trained the soldiers and with
two or three swoops the ISIS captured so
many weapons that Iraq army even doesn't
have it the armoured equipment missiles
etc I don't think it's the knowledge of
the broad community but now Isis is
found better than the Iraq army
supported by the US ok is they withdrawn
but our special services and the
information for Marc shows that
thousands of American troops are still
in Iraq and what's the result quite said
one and quite a tragic one and we would
not like the same thing to be repeated
in Syria and we are urging all our
partners including the u.s. the
Europeans but primarily the u.s. to take
additional efforts to make additional
efforts to fight this absolute evil of
fundamentalism the so called
as Islamic state and some other groups
of the same kind which in the essence
are just branches of the notorious
terrorist organizations global terrorist
organizations which actually stroke
struck upon the u.s. themselves we are
urging to find the political settlement
way which of course would provide for
transformation of the political regime
and we are ready to discuss that with
President Assad as well by the way just
recently in the UN it an opportunity to
call of cooperation with President Assad
was declared in struggling with Isis and
other terrorist groups informations and
we are ready to work with the press
for the sake of providing political
transformation for all the people living
in Syria feeling the access to the
instruments of power of course in order
to avoid the military solution of the
conflict it can't be done from outside
with use of force that's the matter but
are you prepared to urge Assad to step
down if it would lead to an alternative
political solution that would be a
bulwark against Isis going into Damascus
well our moderator is a real American I
say our saying without external
interference and they he's saying
whether I were ready to purge only
Syrian people can urge president to step
down
that's Elementary